une bonne raison trinquer le prix des
vins californiens devrait baisser cette
année il n'y a pas si longtemps les
vignerons planter de nouvelles vignes en
californie pour étancher la soif
toujours plus grande des consommateurs
mais après deux décennies de croissance
la demande est en baisse alors que la
production de raisin est atteint du
niveau record comme d'habitude c'est un
peu la force des mines et mario qui
jettent leur dévolu sur les spiritueux
et les cocktails déjà préparé
conséquence le prix des vins
californiens de faire diminuer et
atteindre son plus bas niveau depuis
plusieurs années les prix devraient
rester bas pendant au moins quelques
années le temps que le marché se
stabilise